[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il s'agit a dit le général de Gaulle de
reconnaître le monde tel qu'il est et
dans ce sens il n'est pas possible
d'oublier à l'autre extrémité du
continent européen asiatique cette Chine
ce très vaste pays géographiquement
compact et pourtant sans unité un état
plus ancien que l'histoire ou un grand
peuple le plus nombreux de la terre
abâti une très particulière et très
profonde civilisation qui conjugue le
goût de la tradition avec le respect de
l'étude et de la science ce peuple
conscient et orgueilleux d'une immuable
pérennité la Chine de
toujours cette Chine de 700 millions
d'êtres qui est aujourd'hui celle qu'a
fait au prix de terrible souffrances
humaines et d'une implacable contrainte
des masses maotsetou il nétait cependant
voici 16 ans qu'un chef de partie vaincu
lorsque le rencontra notre reporter dans
les cavernes de Yenan après cette
retraite historique de 10000 km qu'on a
nommé la longue marche un an après il
entraite à Pékin et installé le régime
communiste sur la Chine
entière depuis un énorme effort a été
accompli le palais des Fils du Ciel au
cœur de la ville interdite voisine avec
un nouveau Pékin moderne ou si les
voitures sont rares les immeubles ont
poussé de toutes parts pour abriter une
population chaque jour plus
nombreuse le pantalon et la veste bleue
ont remplacé pour tous hommes femmes et
enfants les vêures multicolor
d'autrefois la hantise de l'hygiène et
la lutte contre les épidémies la lutte
contre la faim endémique et le
développement des possibilités agricoles
ont pris la première place dans les
préoccupations publiques cet immense
effor s manifesté dans dans tous les
domaines si l'on compte encore les
usines les communications et les travaux
d'irrigation ont commencé à changer le
visage de la très ancienne terre de
Chine comment laisser à l'écart cet
immense pays en pleine évolution ce
peuple innombrable en marche c'est ce
qui apparaît avec le poids de l'évidence
et de la raison ce vide la France va le
combler renouant ainsi avec un peuple
dont la capacité patiente et laborieuse
a toujours suscité l'admiration et qui
est capable de déployer des trésors de
courage et d'ingéniosité quelles que soi
les
circonstances ce langage le général de
Gaulle l'a tenu devant un millier de
journaliste parlant de
l'Asie sur ce continent il n'y a pas une
paix et il n'y a pas une guerre
imaginable sans qu'elle y soit
impliqué et il est
inconcevable de supposer qu'on puisse
jamais conclure
un traité de
neutralité
concernant les États du Sud-Est
asiatique auquel nous Français portons
une attention toute spéciale et
cordiale sans que la Chine en soit
partie neutralité qui paraît bien dans
la période où nous
sommes être la seule situation qui soit
compatible avec la vie paisible et le
progrès des
populations il est
clair que la
France doit pouvoir entendre directement
la Chine et aussi s'en faire
écouter mais il se peut
aussi que dans l'immense évolution
actuelle du monde
en
multipliant les contacts directs de
peuple à peuple on serve la cause des
hommes c'est-à-dire celle de la sagesse
du progrès et de la
paix puis le général de Gaulle envent au
problème de sa succession à la
présidence de la République vous m'avez
demandé
monsieur ce que je ferai dans 2
ans je je ne peux pas et je ne veux pas
vous
répondre alors comme ça pour vous
monsieur X ce sera le général de Gaulle
[Musique]
mes les statutes monumentales de Rams 2
et les temples d'Abou Simbel dont elles
défendent l'entrée depuis plus de 3
millénair ne seront pas engloutis sous
66 m d'eau après la mise en service du
barrage
d'Assouan l'opération de sauvetage
lancée par l'UNESCO est aujourd'hui
passée dans dans sa phase active les
temples sont entre les mains des
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maîtres mais il faudra de 5 à 7 années
encore pour mener à bien ce nouveau
travail d'Hercule qui coûtera 18
milliards d'anciens francs et qui sera
la plus impressionnante entreprise du
genre de tous les temps il s'agite en
effet de surélever toute la masse des
temples au-dessus du niveau du futur lac
[Musique]
artificiel
devant la fusée Saturne installée sur sa
rampe de lancement à Cap Kennedy devant
cette masse haute de 51 m et lourde de
562 tonnes les techniciens américains
ont pu avoir la sensation de vivre un
moment historique de la course pour
l'espace ils étaient TR pour surveiller
le lancement de ce géant qui mettait
enfin les États-Unis à égalité avec
l'URSS utilisant l'hydrogène liquide
pour l'alimentation des six moteurs du
second étage saturne est en effet la
première fusée qui é é capable de
satelliser 17 tonnes et le président
Johnson assistant devant son poste de
télévision au succès du lancement a pu
mesurer le chemin parcouru depuis les
déboires du célèbre pamplemousse qui fit
si triste mine 3 mois après le premier
spoutnic Gaston nessins a quitter la
Corse pour se rendre à Paris à la
convocation du juge d'instruction
pourtant Monsieur Daniel Davy qui lui
offrait de venir travailler en Écosse
est venu lui renouveler sa proposition
et à l'aérodrome de Bastia où il a
embrassé sa femme et sa fillette 400 éta
ven le saluer 400 personnes qui
entretiennent encore autour de
l'anablast l'espoir insensé d'une
[Musique]
guérison mais à Paris Gaston nessin
n'était plus que le
pseudobiologiste attendu par le juge
Rousel qui lui notifia l'inculpation
d'exercice illégal de la médecine et de
la
[Musique]
pharmacie
c'est en présence de 50000 personnes que
s'est déroulé l'ouverture des 9è Jeux
olympiques d'hiver àbrck le docteur
Charf président de la République
autrichienne a accueilli les
représentants des 36 nations
participantes avant l'envoi des couleurs
et la cérémonie du flambau olympique un
couple heureux parmi la foule
l'Impératrice faradiba et le
[Musique]
chatiran les jeux sont ouverts les
premières épreuves débutent par une
surprise en patinage artique attend le
couple champion du monde les Allemands
Mar k
etanler ce ne sont pas eux qui ont
remporté la médaille d'or les vainqueurs
vous les voyez en ce moment ce sont les
Soviétiques de leningrade ludmiaova ETG
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
protopop mais ce sont surtout les
épreuves de skion
attendait
concur malchanceux a l'allure d'un feu
d'artifice avec bien entendu le grand
soleil le français JeanClaude a ét la
victime numéro 1 de ce fe
[Musique]
d'artifice mais la déception a été
largement compensé par la de lo laro que
voici en pleine
[Musique]
action sil avit cravantage à la victoire
Léo laro aurait pu être champion
olympique de la descente il termine à4 C
seulement du vainur
l'autrichi
on cimmerman a confirmé qu'il est bien
cette année le meilleur descendeur du
monde dans cette spécialité il est quasi
imbattable cimerman je suis content
d'avoir gagné la croix j'espère faire
mieux la prochaine fois mais chez les
skilleuses pas de problème les sœurs
guadchell se partagent à de toute la
gloire à part égal au slalom spécial
Marielle la cadette dossard numéro 1
gagne la première manche dans un style
éblouissant elle est si parfaite qu'on
na pas l'impression qu'elle force son
[Musique]
talent un mois la deuxième manche
s'empresse de rétorquer Christine l'aîné
qui devient finalement championne
olympique du spécial casselan tienne
Mariel sera elle aussi championne
olympique 2 jours plus tard du slalom
géant devant sa sœur
justement avec ces deux jeunes filles
prodiges les résultats c'est blanc
bonnet bonnet blanc pour la plus grande
gloire du Ski Français qui est devenu br
le premier du
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monde il ne se passe pas de jours que le
sang ne coule à Chypre les 5000 soldats
britanniques chargés de maintenir
l'ordre sont aujourd'hui incapables
d'éviter ces drames soudains où
s'affronte grec et turc si de nouveau la
violence se déchaîne à Chypre elle ne
reste pas sans écho dans Athènes une
manifestation conduite par des prêtres
orthodoxes et des étudiants a conué
l'idée d' intervention de l'OTAN mais
l'affaire de Chipre est sur la voie de
l'internationalisation dans l'île chaque
communauté vit dans la peur de l'autre
et quand les uns après les autres les
villages entiers se replient comme le
village turc d'adios soseménos où l'on
compta 11 morts comment imaginer qu'une
solution intérieur pourra rapprocher les
deux
[Musique]
group la Hollande respire bien que 10000
personnes a failli périr étouffé devant
le palais royal où le prince et la reine
Juliana ramen leur fille Irène et son
fiancé le prince HUG de bourbonpme il
n'y a plus de mystère les cœurs sensible
y ont trouvé leur compte après 10 jours
de suspense qui ont mis la Hollande au
bord d'une crise constitutionnelle
l'amour a donc été le plus fort et comme
l'a dit avec à propos le Premier
ministre néerlandais tout est bien qui
finit bien tout le monde aime les
[Musique]
amoureux
pour la première fois nous avons pu
visiter à ville juuif une réalisation de
l'État dans le domaine de la lutte
anti-ancer un institut dépendant du
Centre national de la recherche
scientifique aidé par une association en
faveur du développement de cet institut
plus de 300 chercheurs et techniciens
travaillent ici Monsieur Pierre grabard
dirige l'Institut de Recherche
scientifique sur le cancer l'expérience
sur l'homme étant impensable la plupart
des études sont faites sur des animaux
mais on sait que les résultats pourront
être appliqués au cancer humain en
liaison avec la sécurité sociale des
études sont poursuivies sur des
prélèvements fournis par les hôpitaux
parisiens dans l'animalerie 25000 sujets
sont rassemblés des rats souris hamster
de race pur donnent plus de garantie aux
expérimentations depuis peu des singes
sont aussi
utilisés voici un appareil permettant
des expériences sur des souris et des
rats de souche pur qui naissent et
vivent en milieu stérile on pourra ainsi
contrôler plus étroitement sur ces
animaux l'apparition des cancers et des
[Musique]
leucémies chaque chef de service va vous
indiquer brièvement l'activité de son
laboratoire en médecine expérimentale
notre activité s'exerce sur diverses
formes de cancer spontané greffé comme
sur cette UF de
poule ou encore provoqué virus radiation
ou corps chimique comme sur ce
rat dans le laboratoire d'étude du tabac
nous avons mis au point une méthode par
badigeonnage de souris au goudron de
fumée et par examen de la peau au
microscope pour apprécier la diminution
de nosivité des cigarettes expérimenté
par la Régie française des
tabac le laboratoire de biochimie
analyse les constituants de la cellule
vivante par exemple les acides
nucléiques une modification de leur
structure pourrait expliquer la
cancérisation en virologie on étudie les
virus d'origine humaine et animale
capable de provoquer des tumeur chez les
animaux et de transformer des cellules
normales en cellules
cancéreuses la connaissance du mécanisme
de tel transformation permettrait de
comprendre le processus de la
cancérisation chez l'homme
la microscopie électronique a permis des
grossissement d'un million de fois voici
la photographie originale d'un virus
cancérigène du singe d'un autre virus
qui provient de la souris et voici la
maquette de sa structure moléculaire on
a pu photographier un grand nombre de
virus dans les cancers d'animaux et l'on
essae maintenant de les découvrir chez
l'homme les méthodes immunologiques
permettent de déceler les modifications
des constituants des cellules
cancéreuses on peut ainsi espérer
approcher le problème de la défense
contre le cancer comme on le fait pour
les maladies infectieuses en liaison
avec cet institut h laboratoires sont
dirigés par le professeur le Breton
cette rapide enquête montre la
complexité de la recherche réclamant des
équipes de spécialistes très différents
et la part prise par cet institut aux
recherches sur le
cancer
final au transatlantique de l'aviatrice
françaiseatteriss à
rioan dans pe avion
deevx réalis son exp solitaire sur la
route de
[Musique]
mer de l' interplanire très
grand bienoit désor de goûter de
gloire
[Musique]
grand rendez-vous du rugby international
pour le match France All Blacks au stade
du manoir à colombe dans les tribunes
archicomble trois spectateurs attentifs
le duc de Winsor monsieur Chaband Delm
et Monsieur Foucher ça commence bien
pour l'équipe de France al baladj marque
les trois premiers points du match après
4 minutes de jeu c'est ensuite une
sévère mais correcte explication d'avant
les grands joueurs noirs des Antipodes
n'en sont pas encore revenus les
Français font presque jeu égal avec eux
ce qui ne les empêche pas d'égaler sur
coup
franc ce coup franc va être suivi d'un
essai les All Black ont cette qualité
ils ne pardonnent aucune faute à leurs
adversaires un mauvais dégagement de
Gachassin et voilà trois points de plus
pour les
néozélandais et pourtant les Français
n'en font pas beaucoup des fautes dans
toutes les phases du jeu la balle coûte
cher mais que c'est passionnant le
rugby une poussée comme cela à la mêlée
ça se mesure en tonnes de muscles après
la poussée c'est le feu d'artifice des
attaquants français des envoyés de ce
style il y en a eu tout au long de la
deè
mi-temps mais vraiment les Français ont
donné une idée flatteuse de le rugby et
ça fuse encore le tout petit AER
Gachassin numéro 14 n'a pas peur des
grands ce qu'empêche pas d'aller au
massacre les grands maillot noir d'en
face profite de tout il ne laisse pas
souffler les Français qui ont les jambes
coupées par un drop de laid l'eau
la victoire des néozélandais est
incontestable mais un peu sévère pour la
France qui ne méritait pas d'encaisser
un nouvel essai quoi qu'il en soit dans
tout cela le véritable gagnant c'est le
rugby aux Jeux Olympiques d'insbr
Marielle guchel a manqué sa sortie dans
l'épreuve de descente comme toutes les
Françaises elle a été surclassée dans la
dernière épreuve féminine cependant elle
a tout de même la consolation d'être
sacré championne du monde du combiné la
grande triomphatrice de la descente la
voilà c'est l'Autrichienne
crystal crystal SK comme un homme elle
en a le poids et le gabarit bref dans
cette spécialité elle est
imbattable on croyait àin calma
imbattable lui aussi au patinage
artistique le résultat vous le voyez ses
NIR ont craqué il a tout
[Musique]
manqué c'est un véritable festival de
chute et ce n'est pas son magnifique
finale qui aurait pu changer quoi que ce
fut au résultat il revient de loin avec
sa médaille
[Musique]
d'argent le vainqueur c'est l'alemand
schneldorfer il est très appliqué
schneldorfer mais il n'a pas la classe
d'un champion olympique si avait été
lui-même il n'y aurait pas eu de
[Musique]
problème les deux premiers avec la
vedette de demain l'Américain Allen
médaille de bronze en attendant
[Musique]
mieux les skilleurs Français ont imité
leurs compatriotes féminin eux aussi ils
ont manqué leur sortie per a beau gagné
avec une facilité dérisoire la deuxè
manche du slalom spécial il est trop
tard de la première manche est
impardonnable il est pourtant le
meilleur slalomer mondial dans ces
conditions c'est l'Autrichien PPPI
stigler sur qui personne ne comptait qui
tire les marrons du feu derrière lui
deux Américains inattendus également
William Kid et Jimmy
[Musique]
Yuga au grand trempelin une faute a
coûté la médaille d'or au au Finlandais
k Konen il a complètement manqué son
arrivée au
sol ce qui a profité à son vieux rival
norvégien thoralf engam champion
olympique
[Musique]
1964 tous les observateurs ont constaté
l'extrême cordialité qui a marqué la
visite du chancelier herart à Paris en
compagnie de cinq de ses ministres une
visite qui devait comporter deux
entretiens en tête à-tête avec le
général de Gaulle à l'Élysée et un large
tour d'horizon entre les gouvernements
des deux
[Musique]
pays une visite de travail qui entrait
dans le cadre du traité de coopération
de 1963 et dont le chancelier s'est
déclaré particulièrement
[Musique]
satisfait dans le rapprochement
franco-allemand le RIN a retrouvé
aujourd'hui sa vocation de grand artère
de communication européenne et voici que
l'aménagement de la Mzelle vient de lui
donner un prolongement vers la Lorine
deux automoteurs Renant l'un allemand le
RIN rour 8 l'autre français le kantnac
muni d'un radar permettant la navigation
de nuit ou par brouillard ont effectué
ensemble le premier voyage commercial de
celin Saville au passage de l'écluse de
palzem la foule luxembourgeoise a salué
comme il le méritait l'événement que
constitue la mise en service de cette
voie nouvelle ouverte entre l'Allemagne
le Luxembourg et la France la
canalisation de la Moselle ne
pose-t-elle pas le premier jalon de la
liaison Rin rô du grand axe navigable
Nord sudud APAC c'est l'écluse des trois
frontière celle où l'on prend conscience
de l'aspect collectif
franco-germano-lxembourgeois d'une œuvre
qui a été accomplie en 7 ans sur 270 km
des dérivations ont été créées des éclus
édifiés le chenal a été creusé dans dans
le lit de la rivière à une profondeur de
2 M90 et au mois de mai des bateaux de
1500 tonnes l'équivalent d'un train et
demi de marchandises et des convois
poussés comportant deux barges de 1600
tonnes l'équivalent de trois trains de
marchandise pourront s'engager sur cette
voie de gabarit international alors
thville et la cidérurgie Lorine auront
accès direct au bassin de la Roure et au
port de
[Musique]
rotterdame
les massacres de limasol ont amené la
crise cypriote à son point culminant
pendant plusieurs jours les rues de la
deè ville de Lille ont été le théâtre de
violent combat des Grecs armés ont
entrepris un véritable nettoyage du
quartier turc utilisant même des
bulldozers
blindés désormais c'est l'état d'alerte
permanent entre les deux communautés le
recours au Conseil de sécurité n'était
plus évitable après l'échec auprès de
Monseig macarios du numéro 2 de la
diplomatie américaine monsieur George
ball celui-ci avait tenté de faire
accepter la présence d'une force du
commonweals pour relayer les troupes
britanniques à l'heure où le port de
famagust vivait dans la hantise d'une
intervention directe de la flotte
turque l'ONU parviendra-t-elle à éviter
aux Grecs et au Turcs de continuer à
[Musique]
s'entretuer
voici une année qui nous offre un jour
de plus un jour de plus dit un proverbe
africain ne fais pas courir l'éléphant
mais que faire d'un jour de plus madame
que pensez-vous du 29 février et bien
monsieur pour moi c'est une chance la
période justement de mes vacances qui me
permet de passer une journée de PL avec
mes
enfants bien moi ça m'ennu assez parce
que je suis né le 29 février alors d'un
seul coup du jour au lendemain j'ai 4 de
plus oh moi je trouve ça très pratique
au contraire pour les cadeaux ça me fera
un jour de plus qui me coûter aussi cher
que les autres un jour de plus c'est une
chance de plus avec la tranche spéciale
j'espère devenir millionnaire sentolé au
mois de février ça fait un jour de
robe la vie moderne éant ce qu'elle est
on pourrait croire les pauvres citadins
voués à une perpétuelle surexcitation
nerveuse il existe pourtant un remède
vieux du reste comme le monde capable de
sauver de leur insomnie les victimes du
siècle de la
précipitation regardez bien cet homme ne
croyez pas qu'il marche comme vous et
moi il rythme sa respiration sur ses pas
il contrôle chacun de ses mouvements il
pratique le ATA yoga voilà le grand mot
lâché et nous avons demandé à Monsieur
Ferrer de nous en dévoiler les
mystères pour par réaliser ce que le
yoga prétend nous faire réaliser et bien
il y a plusieurs manières notamment il y
a le yoga le
yoga c'est c'est une forme de yoga qui
utilise comme trin l'énergie a signifie
a signifie l'énergie positive
th signifie l'énergie
négative voilà qui est clair et à partir
de là 800 postures permettent de
contrôler et éduquer le moindre muscle
le moindre élément du corps
humain citons le porvotana autrement dit
la chandelle qui a pour vertu
particulière de faciliter
l'élocution le vipari takarini est une
posture de repos qui apporte déteinte et
lucidité chacune de ces positions
toujours difficilees exige est-il besoin
de le préciser une concentration totale
autant de pauses qui sont autant de
recettes à chacune des complications des
difficultés de notre agité tout peut
être résolu même le trac j'aiu cel
surtout dans le monde des artistes dans
le monde des élèves qui vont passer leur
bac oui sont le TR TR corrige facilement
en pour yogi facilement en agissant sur
le centre d'énergie cardiaque
chak saluons donc aujourd'hui les vertus
séculaires hautement calmantes du at
yoga
[Musique]
c'est sous le signe de la bonne humeur
et des de mari l'enfant terrible du SK
alpin que s'est déroulé la réception
offerte à l'hôtel matigon par le Premier
ministre monsieur George Pompidou au
membres de l'équipe Française de Ski
pour une fois on avait oublié le
protocole dans l'ostè maison de la rue
de
varen
mais ce n'était là qu'un entract pour
les jeunes skieurs français qui dès le
lendemain reprenaient la compétition sur
les pistes de Garmish Parton kir en
Allemagne de l'Ouest où se sont déroulé
les épreuves du
Kandar Mar profiter de cette nouvelle
occasion pour prouver qu'elle est bien
la meilleure skilleuse du monde elle a
gagné le combiné tout
[Musique]
comm cepend cette victoire mari a d
céder la première place du slom spécial
à
l'amricaine comme elle l'a dit elleême
il faut bien qu'elle laisse tout de même
de temps en temps une consolation à
rival jeude le faux fiancé Mar c'est le
grand champion de de dont on attend
pourant un exploit un peu avant la
lettre il pas d'exploit au je Olympi
jeanud accumul les fa
pas
la malchance ne pouvait pas durer
indéfiniment et à garmich au slalom
géant du candard il a montré ce qu'il
savait faire regardez-le bien ce Skille
là c'est l'un des champions olympiques
de
demain la porte des grandes victoires
est enfin ouverte à Jean-Claude k déjà
prêt à assurer la relève des bonslieux
et des
[Musique]
Lacroix le match franceangleterre de
rugby a été pour l'équipe française et
pour les spectateurs du stable de
colombe match
des Français maillot foncant très
prometteur mais les avant sont bien vite
englu dans les M ouvertes habilement
étouffé par les Anglais m offens comme
celu il en a beaucoup CER à chaque
foisependant les atts man vite de et pu
lefut majeur c'est le lur dans la
transmission de
laect
laite pour les Anglais avec
cou anglais bien
admiratrice et ce mouvement magnifique
qui va amener lesess français ce sera
quand même la plus belle attaque de tout
le
match all mademoiselle vozvous la
face tout de même rien les
arrête au cours de la deè mi-temps au
début du moins on croit qu'il est encore
possible à la France de prendre
l'avantage piqu le centre droit se fait
souffler une balle on se demande encore
comment et c'est le départ de toute la
cavalerie
anglaise
ce mouvement illustre la supériorité des
Anglais sur les Français dans tous les
compartiments du
jeu c'est un véritable déferlement qui
aboutira à l'essai de la victoire dans
cette phase de jeu les Français sont
complètement
affolé on cherche encore une explication
à ce passage à vite de l'équipe de
France qui a définitivement perdu le
tournoi desessin nation cette année
la visite que le Président de la
République italienne monsieur Antonio se
a rendu à Paris et qui a conduit au côté
du général de Gaulle sur le tombeau du
soldat inconnu a souligner l'amitié qui
unit traditionnellement la France et
[Musique]
l'Italie ce voyage aussi le mérite à
l'occasion des entretiens des de chefs
d'État de la position des deux
partenaires du Marché
Commun premier effet de la reprise des
relations entre Paris et Pékin le
premier chargé d'affaires de la Chine
populaire est arrivé à Paris en même
temps que Monsieur chet chargé
d'affaires français arrivit à Pékin nul
doute comme l'a dit lui-même monsieur
sunchang qu'à la faveur de cette reprise
les relations entre les deux pays ne
connaissent un nouveau
développementis du reste s'est déjà mis
à l'heure de la Chine pour son trème
passage dans la capitale française
l'Opéra de Pékin a apporté sur la scène
5000 ans d'art de culture et de
civilisation c'est tout à la fois
l'oreille et l'œil que plonge dans la
surprise des tableaux comme l'attaque de
la forteresse prétexte à de
vertigineuses acrobaties sur des
sonorités
[Musique]
écan
un thème folklorique qui met au prise un
vol de Gru et une bande de vautours
c'est encore l'occasion d'un tourbillon
d'une avalanche de soie et d'étoffes
pailleté
[Musique]
d'or
danse acrobatie poésie musique c'est
tout cela à la fois l'Opéra de
Pékin
2 jours après l'assassinat du président
Kennedy son assassin présumé Lee Oswald
était dans les locaux de la police de
Dallas et en dépit de son escorte de
policier tué à coup de revolver sous
l'œil des caméras par un tenancier de
boîte de nuit Jack
Ruby la cour criminelle de Dallas a donc
aujourd'hui à juger Ruby mais
pourra-t-elle le faire c'est en effet la
question qui se pose dans ce procès qui
drainene laattention générale et autour
duquel des précautions extraordinaires
ont été prises Ruby a pris pour assurer
sa défense l'un des avocats les plus
célèbres et aussi les plus astucieux de
la côte ouest Melvin B qui demande le
transfert de la cause loin de
Dallas le juge Joe Brown a cependant
fait commencer la sélection des jurés
appelés à juger Ruby ils sont 900 et il
en faut 12 on peut donc se demander au
bout de combien de temps Ruby se
trouvera devant ces 12 jurés la défense
et l'accusation en effet font tellement
assaut de défiance que dans la première
semaine de jur seulement ont été
acceptés à ce rythme il faudrait 6
semaines pour avoir un jury complet et
Ruby qu'on amène sous bonne garde de la
prison au tribunal va assister
passivement au curieux début d'un procès
qui comptera sans aucun doute parmi les
procès du
[Musique]
siècle
les derniers becs de gaz de Paris
évoquent aujourd'hui une époque révolue
celle où les braves gazomètres et les
fours à coqu fournissaient ce que l'on
appelait d'ailleurs le gaz d'éclairage
inventé dès la fin du 18e
[Musique]
siècle déjà il y a 150 ans le gaz avait
commencé à éclairer le trait parisien
passage des Pan
aujourd'hui le gaz est devenu gaz de
chauffage et ces dernières années les
réseaux gaziers se sont multipliés à
travers la France en
1963 la région parisienne a consommé
plus de 2 milliards de mètres cubes de
gaz demain le premier bateau métanier
amènera sous forme liquide à -10°r le
gaz naturel du Sahara d'importants
travaux sont en cours au port du Havre
pour le recevoir il viendra compléter
dans les grandes centrales gazières le
mélange déjà préparé à partir du gaz de
lac et du gaz tiré du
charbon les besoins en gaz de chauffage
ont transformé de fonte en comble une
industrie vieille d'un siècle et
[Musique]
demi cette saison chez Christian Dior
Marc bin a fait surgir d'un coup de
baguette magique le couturier n'est-il
pas un magicien une collection jeune
alerte et plus féminine que jamais pas
de révolution ud intempestive mais au
contraire une note sage la note de la
femme dans la vie et en effet les
tailleurs de l'après-midi aux vestes
courtes plus courte sur le devant que
dans le dos tailleur sportif parfois
même à veste longue donne une ligne très
proche de la ligne naturelle buste
souple et hanche affiné par l'évasement
de la
jupe leses detail sont en général des
robes maillot restituant à la femme sa
grâce naturelle et dont la discrétion et
le luxe des détails font le
[Musique]
raffinement
enfin pour les dîners et les grands
soirs les robes ont une nouvelle
longueur elle s'arrête au-dessus de la
cheville avec pour couleur toutes les
teintes que prend le ciel entre le lever
et le coucher du
[Musique]
soleil et tout cela fera un très joli
printemps
parisien
[Musique]